so since I was up on the break let me
reiterate this you have great incredible
value as a human that has nothing to do
with what you get paid what you get paid
is the service you render to the
marketplace if you organize the
antiperspirant aisle in a Walmart that's
what you get paid for if you're the CEO
of Walmart and therefore you organize
all the aisles in all the thousands and
thousands and thousands of stores around
the world that employ thousands and
thousands and thousands of people you
bring more economic value to the
marketplace and you get paid more that
does not mean that the CEO of Walmart or
the CEO of my company me or the CEO of
whatever is worth more as a human being
but it does mean they brought more
economic value to the market your pay is
not based on your worth as a human being
nor should it be
you have great value as a human being
but your pay is based on the economic
value you bring it to the market well
I'm too smart have too many degrees to
make this much money prove it by
bringing economic value to the
marketplace do something that helps
someone do something that serves someone
do something that makes someone's life
better in some way and you will make
more money do it a lot and on a lot of
scale and you'll make even more money
that's how economic value works see
that's the same thing of you know they
say well you know such as such an NFL
quarterback makes ninety million dollars
in his last contract nobody's worth that
kind of money you ever anybody say that
no one should ever be paid that kind of
money see that's someone when you say
that crap that shows your ignorance you
thought that someone was be
paid based on their value as a human
being no they're not more valuable as a
human being than you are
you're just as valuable as a human being
as they are but they brought more
economic value to the marketplace than
you did because believe me the NFL team
could not pay them ninety million
dollars were they not making more than
ninety million dollars as a result of
that guy throwing that football down the
field successfully it's an economic
thing and so if you have a restaurant
and you do a really good job you make
that amount of money for the service you
brought to the economy it does not mean
that you are a more valuable or less
valuable human being and I've met
puffed-up self-important rich people who
think that they're that they're more
valuable as a human being because
they're rich and that's just not true
you're not you're just a person you just
happen to have more green pieces of
paper than the other guy zippy it
doesn't make you more important and I
met people in positions of power and
politics who somehow thought they were
more important and that someone should
care for them but the ones that we all
love the ones we love to meet the quote
important or wealthy or famous or
whatever they are are the ones that
realize that as a human being I have
exactly the same value you do no more no
less I might have brought more or less
economic value to the marketplace than
you brought but those are two separate
discussions let's see in a culture where
everybody gets a trophy
sometimes people stop and think gosh it
means I as a human being am NOT valuable
if I don't get paid the same as someone
else and you know you deserve to be paid
a living wage why because everyone
deserves that why they're entitled to
that why why if you don't do anything to
bring economic value to the marketplace
how have you earned a living wage you
have
see here's the way you ought to look at
the minimum wage what's the minimum
you're willing to bring to the
marketplace how big a fire are you going
to build how big a ruckus are you going
to cause how much service are you going
to provide what's the what's your
minimum level of service that you want
to bring to the market do you think a
waitress that works five days a week
ought to make five times as much as
someone who works one day a week if she
waits five times more tables than then
he does shouldn't she be paid five times
more yes but he deserves a living wage
why he didn't work as much if you want a
living wage try making a living that's
why they call it that making a living
it's it's called going into the
marketplace and finding a way to serve I
figured out that some companies are not
willing to pay me enough for my time
that I can bring more service and
economic value to the market doing other
things than some companies are willing
to pay when I was a 13 year old or a 12
year old or a 14 year old back in those
days
you could actually work at Burger King
and you could be a whopper flupper and I
forget but it seems like in my mind it
seems like minimum wage was a buck 65 an
hour I think that's right I'll have to
go look it up to be sure if I'm wrong
you can destroy me on Twitter as being
an idiot and all you people will that's
fine but I think it was a buck 65 an
hour whatever I figured out that I could
mow grass and make two to three times
more per hour what my buddies were
making flopping whoppers and so I
determined I did not want to bring be a
whopper fluffer
I wanted to be a grass cutter by the way
the grass cutting is outside and I have
hay fever
so I sneezed and I was filthy and I'm in
Tennessee where the humidity is so thick
in August you can cut it with a knife
and so I sweat like an animal at 13
years I think they call that child abuse
covered in dirt from the weed eater and
the lawnmower blowing back on you in the
wind and the humidity is so thick in the
sweat and so it all sticks to you at the
end of the day I remember that like it
was yesterday it feels like - twenty
years ago it was actually 40 years ago
but it feels like in my emotions it was
yesterday I remember every bit of that
but I also remember timing myself on how
quickly I could cut the grass and my
goal was to cut the grass fast enough
and still do a good enough job that I
could make at least twice what my
buddies were making per hour and so I
could work half as much and make the
same money or work the same amount and
make twice as much money because I
provided a different level of economic
value I earned more than they earned
nobody used to strike against Burger
King and McDonald's in those days we
just didn't work for them if we didn't
like what they paid and so if you don't
like what someone pays you're really
saying you are unwilling to provide more
service to the marketplace you need to
bring more economic value to the
marketplace I had a young man working
here one time who had more degrees than
a thermometer and he came into my office
and he said people that have this many
degrees that work in other places make a
lot more than I do and I said well you
can here - we can pay you a whole lot
more but here's the way it works here
your raise is effective when you are
when you bring this organization more
value you can get paid more currently
all we do is shovel all the crap from
around you because you're constantly
spewing it and so try doing something of
value that brings in more money than you
cost and I'll share some of it with you
oh they didn't teach him that at one of
the schools he went to when he was
getting one of his master's degrees
you want more money bring more economic
value to the market regardless of
whether you do that or not though you're
very valuable as a human being but do
not confuse your inherent intrinsic
value as a human being with your
economic value your economic value is
based on one thing and one thing only
the value that you bring to the market
it's not based on your ability to be
pissed off at somebody else because they
don't pay you enough that's your fault
how's that for a weird idea separating
the value of a human being from their
economic value when you separate the two
it really clarifies for some of you
people that grew up in the everybody
gets a trophy generation this is the
Dave Ramsey show
you